[Music]
kanye west has something to say about
all the chatter surrounding his latest
music video for easy i'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face
last week the grammy winner dropped the
controversial visual which shows yay
kidnapping a claymation figure of his
estranged wife kim kardashian's new beau
pete davidson
then burying him in the ground and even
decapitating him god sent me from that
crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
the whole thing ends with a title card
reading everyone lived happily ever
after except you know who with the name
skeet crossed out well on sunday the 44
year old rapper seemingly opened up
about the disturbing video on instagram
posting this image alongside a caption
that reads quote art is therapy just
like this view art is protected as
freedom of speech art inspires and
simplifies the world art is not a proxy
for any ill or harm any suggestion
otherwise about my art is false and mal
intended just something from my heart
kanye released the video last week just
hours after a judge granted kim's
petition to be declared legally single
amid her divorce proceedings with the
musician
while this doesn't mean their divorce is
finalized it does mean kim's considered
a legally single woman while they
continue to work out a divorce
settlement you just gotta roll with it
so what does pete think of yay's new
video well a source tells et that the
snl star is taking it all with a grain
of salt in fact the source adds that he
finds it to be hysterical quote he is
almost flattered by it all because it is
so ridiculous to him it is what it is
the source says that pete isn't
threatened by kanye in any way shape or
form quote he's using this to grow in
more ways than one including for himself
and his relationship with kim he is
turning all of the negativity into a
positive thing i love that energy in my
life in fact according to the source kim
and pete have grown closer from all the
drama
and the 41 year old skim's founder
couldn't be more appreciative of the
comedian who's made an extreme effort to
put his emotions aside and just be a
support system for her during this
difficult time
at the end of the day life is about
being happy
as for kanye he's made it pretty clear
he's trying to get back together with
kim opening up about it on the drink
champs podcast back in november
i want to pull my family back together
and one month later changing the lyrics
to his hit run away
more specifically
e.t source recently explained that
kanye's goal is to break up kim and pete
adding that he'll never accept that his
ex is on a totally different page
as for kim eti source says she's over it
and just wants to move on
[Music]